at least eight people have been killed
after Syrian government airstrikes
targeted a school in Italy province tens
of thousands of civilians have been
fleeing towards the Turkish border to
escape the escalation in violence
government forces and their Russian
allies are pushing deeper into the last
rebel stronghold in Italy the N
Secretary General has called for an
immediate end to the violence in
northern is Syria they want to kill
people before they escape here while
we're pecking the JIT came and targeted
us and killed a large number and injured
others and a whole family is missing
it's gone out to Mohammed a doe who is
live for us Mohammed the violence
continues and very close to where you
are of course there's a huge number of
refugees fleeing yes indeed Julie we are
right on the border of Turkey and Syria
and behind me it's a bit hazy but you
can make out the atma refugee camp it's
one of the biggest of the comes that
line up the turkey Syrian border now a
crisis is unfolding on the other side of
the border 125,000 people who fled their
homes because of the current onslaught
by Syrian armed forces was supported by
Russia has sent them out of their homes
and many of them are living in there
open the cops are full so they cannot be
accommodated some of them have set up
next shift shelters to what of the cold
because it is right in the middle of
winter which has been very harsh so far
rains are expected to come in the next
48 hours also and turkey is not budging
it says it's not going to allow one more
Syrian refugee to cross the border so
those people are in limbo they are out
in the cold and at the mercy of the
elements Mohamed are we expecting the
military campaign to go on as it has
been and if that's the case where can
refugees turn to
well the military operation is still
going on and it's not expected to stop
and it's time because Bashar al-assad's
government is really hell-bent on
getting every last inch of Syrian
territory in the hands of our position
ad-lib as we know is the last opposition
stronghold and in the past few days of
clashes they've been making steady
progress taking over at least 20 terms
and villages and they're getting closer
and closer to the strategic city of
Marathon Man which sits right across the
m5 highway which links Damascus to
Aleppo something Bashar al-assad is keen
to get his hands on because of trade and
also linking cities under his control
the opposition fighters have been
putting on a stiff resistance they
managed to recover at least three of
those villages that had been taken over
by the Syrian government forces who are
being supported with airstrikes by the
Russians and it doesn't look as if it's
going to stop which means more people
will be leaving their homes and joining
the people who are already living out in
the open how are they joining us live
there from Rehan Lee Mohammad thank you